GET HIM
DUNK, REBOUND, THE ON THAT.
>> WHAT ARE
FLAVOR TO IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SUPPLEMENT.
GETS LL, FOR 3.
>> THAT IS A BIG
GOOD!
>> YOU GOT TO LOVE IT, GOT HIS
BELT.
RECOGNIZE HE G UNIT IN REALLY E
THAT IS THE STORY.
IT IS GOOD.
MORRIS A LOT NVER REGAINED THE
EVERYBODY ROTATING, DENVER.
>> THEY ARE LOOKING TO FIND
HIM.
SECONDS FOR THE HELP.
FOR JONES, GOT IT FIRED.
TO JONES, HE DID IT.
IT IS SHORT FROM THE SIDE OF BA
BARTON RUNNING TO BY BALL.
AND
HE FADED IN THE CORNER.
ING
CONTINUE NOW, OFF TO THE
BULLS.
GORDON PICKS HIM UP.
FIRES IT.
GETS ITITTHE
BREAK.
DID NOT LIKE THE
>> CAMPAZZO AND GORDON VEN TO B
SHOOT KICK.
CREATING THE BARRIER AROUND THE
BASKET.
EVERYONE
RUNS IT.
BACK TO BRADLEY.
IS GOOD JOB SO
>> TO THE RIM,
LEARNING IT.
JOKIC THAT TO GET IT.
JOKIC TRYING TO GET POSITION.
>> AND THAT IS TO CONNECT ON TH
ONE.
>> JONES, HE STAYED AN NBA.
JONES ROLLS, STEPS THROUGH.
FOUL.
AWAY.
BULLS HAVE AN STEPPED UP IS WHA
>> WON